[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec à
mes côtés petit bonhomme bon gentil
bonjour rien et notre invité cette
semaine et jean pierre door voulons
jouer députés les républicains du loiret
merci d'être avec nous merci bien
et dans l'actualité parlementaire cette
semaine il ya d'abord les suites de la
sphère benalla au sénat
le bureau de la haute assemblée a décidé
de poursuivre alexandre benalla pour
parjure l'écart des trois hauts
responsables de l'elysée seront si
transmis à la justice l'exécutif a très
vivement réagi le premier ministre
edouard philippe a refusé de se rendre
au sénat pour les questions gouvernement
jeudi l'exécutif qui est aussi dû
répondre à un feu nourri de questions
sur sa gestion des violences survenues
lors des manifestations du 16 mars après
les nouvelles images de dégradations sur
les champs elysées le ministre de
l'intérieur a dû s'expliquer devant les
sénateurs mardi la loi santé examiné à
l'assemblée nationale
elle instaure la fin du numerus clausus
pour les études de médecine
mais cela suffira-t-il à résoudre la
question des déserts médicaux
l'opposition en doute le gouvernement
feint veut-il reculer l'âge de légal de
départ à la retraite oui non peut-être
l'exécutif a louvoyé toute la semaine en
multipliant les déclarations parfois
contradictoires finalement le premier
ministre a tenté de clarifier sa
position mercredi lors des questions au
gouvernement
et on commence cette semaine avec la
sphère benalla qui ravive les tensions
entre le sénat et l'exécutif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi le bureau du sénat a donc décidé
de transmettre à la justice les cas
d'alexandre benalla et de vincent kraz
mais aussi de trois collaborateurs de
l'elysée auditionné par la commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale
une décision qui a déclenché la colère
de l'exécutif qui dénonce une décision
politique
je ne suis en guerre contre personne a
répondu gérard larcher le président du
sénat mais fait rare le premier ministre
a boycotté la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement jeudi
jonathan du prix y est l'issue du vote
était incertaine les sénateurs ont
décidé de transmettre à la justice les
cas des trois hauts responsables de la
présidence
alexis colère secrétaire général de
l'elysée le général lionel lavergne chef
du gspr et patrick strzoda directeur de
cabinet des manuels macron la commission
d' enquête parlementaire leur reprochait
d'avoir retenu une part significative de
la vérité lors des auditions
certains membres du bureau salue une
décision cohérente
c'était un rendez vous à ne pas manquer
personne n'aurait compris que le bureau
des juges le travail remarquable de la
commission d' enquête qui a été menée
par philippe braun chercheur émérite
jourdain avec la plus grande rigueur
sans jamais aucun dérapage la commission
d'enquêté rester dans son couloir tout
du long
on ne mélange pas les genres et en
respectant scrupuleusement la séparation
des pouvoirs qui est essentielle dans
cette république est cette démocratie
à l'unanimité les sénateurs ont voté la
transmission des cas d'alexandre benalla
et vincent kraz mais sur les 26 membres
du bureau
six ont voté contre la transmission du
castro da à la justice et 7 contre celle
d'alexis colère et lionel lavergne
majoritairement des centristes pour
qu'ils le sénat est allé trop loin
un certain nombre de mise en
responsabilité et est superfétatoire
il ya eu un travail important qui a été
fait par cette commission denquête au
monde l'a reconnu c'était l'honneur du
sénat que de contrôler l'exécutif comme
l'a fait
le sénat et la commission denquête où il
ya eu une chose peut-être qui est allé
un peu trop loin
à mes yeux et qui était pas
nécessairement justifié c'est la mise en
cause d'un certain nombre de
responsables au plus haut niveau de
l'état
de son côté le parti présidentiel accuse
le coup le président du groupe lrm au
sénat dénonce un procès politique où je
considère aujourd'hui que sans doute
c'est de la peur du sénat une volonté
manifeste de mettre à mal
l'exécutif les sénateurs rappellent
toutefois que la décision du bureau ne
vaut pas condamnation et qu'elle ne
saurait se substituer au travail de la
justice
jean-pierre de rhazoui pour vous le
sénat eu raison de transmettre les cas
des trois collaborateurs de l'elysée à
la justice mais je crois que oui parce
qu'ils ont fait un travail remarquable
j'ai pu en avoir connaissance par
l'intermédiaire d'un sénateur de mon
département qui est donc co rapporteurs
de ceux de cette commission denquête oui
celle du de l'assemblée nationale comme
vous le savez elle a échoué complètement
puisque il eu des refus de d'auditions
auprès de cette commission denquête du
de l'assemblée nationale le sénat a fait
un travail formidable pendant des
semaines et même des mois ils arrivent à
des conclusions
ses conclusions dans la démocratie c'est
de respecter l'ensemble de ses
conclusions
donc comme il y a eu soit disant des des
rondes et comment dirais-je des photos
ou tout au moins que l'on peut penser à
des fautes en ayant caché certaines
choses
bon bah ils vont jusqu'au bout et ils
ont décidé majoritairement à poursuivre
en justice cela s'effectue c'est logique
maintenant ce sera à la justice de
trancher mais sont des règles
démocratiques et c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs qu'il faut respecter
donc moi je comprends mal la réaction de
l'exécutif
l'exécutif devrait accepter cette
décision
c'est le rôle aussi de l'exécutif de
respecter les décisions des chambres
parlementaires la réaction de l'exécutif
justement le premier istres donc
boycotté la séance de questions au
gouvernement au sénat jeudi comment vous
jugez cette réaction jeu
je ça dommageable parce que je pense que
le rôle de l'exécutif c'est de respecter
les décisions de des chambres
parlementaires c'est la décision du
sénat elle est tout à fait respectable
majoritairement ils ont décidé de
d'aller plus loin et de conclure leur
commission denquête parce trans cette
transmission au palais donc on verra
bien ensuite ce qu'il adviendra mais je
n'imagine pas que le sénat ait puisse
mettre dans un tiroir
leurs conclusions en disant bon
maintenant il n'y a plus rien à voir
et le gouvernement parle de procès
politique ce n'est pas une décision
politique du sénat les républicains du
sénat liés aux c'est aux socialistes au
sénat
ça c'est de la petite cuisine politique
médiatique non je crois qu'ils ont fait
un travail formidable toute opinion le
respecté au sein du sénat
maintenant ils arrivent à des
conclusions il faut en tirer les
conséquences
donc c'est pas un procès politique c'est
un un procès envers des personnes qui
n'ont qui ont qui n'ont pas respecté le
serment qu'ils avaient engagée
lorsqu'ils sont venus dans les auditions
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale a décidé d'annuler
un déplacement commun imprévue avec son
homologue du sénat gérard larcher il dit
que cette décision c'est un abaissement
du parlement et parle aussi lui il parle
lui aussi de décisions politiques
comment vos qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'attitude de richard ferrand je pense
que c'est une une une à une décision
maladroite pense que richard ferrand est
là pour défendre le parlement et le
parlement il est il a deux chambres
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
donc il faut qu'il respecte les
décisions des chambres il est un
représentant de peuples il un
représentant des députés donc il doit
aussi il joue pas son rôle pour vous le
défenseur n'a pas joué son rôle il
aurait dû respecter lui aussi les
décisions du sénat imaginons que ce soit
l' inverse il images je pense qu'il ne
serait pas satisfait si c'était le
président du sénat qui venait contrarier
des décisions de l'assemblée nationale
il y une séparation des pouvoirs entre
l'exécutif
les deux chambres c'est la démocratie
donc si on veut remettre en avant le
rôle des chambres parlementaires qui
sont contestés aujourd'hui dans les
grands débats on le voit bien au niveau
de ce qui se passe au niveau des gilets
jaunes et bien il faut aussi montrer que
nous faisons notre travail de
parlementaire et c'est démocratique
allez on en vient à notre deuxième thème
cette semaine le sénat a demandé des
explications à l'exécutif sur les
violences à paris les ministres de
l'intérieur et de l'économie se sont
expliqués mardi devant les commissions
des lois et des affaires économiques du
sénat sur les violences qui ont émaillé
la ctt 18d gilet jaune samedi à paris
attendu au tournant
le ministre de l'intérieur n'a pas
convaincu l'ensemble des sénateurs
jonathan dupriez dans la même salle
au même moment christophe castaner
laurent nunez et bruno le maire ont dû
rendre des comptes aux sénateurs d'abord
sur les conséquences économiques liées
aux dégradations des casseurs mais
surtout sur les dysfonctionnements en
matière de maintien de l'ordre
samedi dernier les a eus à la fois des
dysfonctionnements dans l'application la
doctrine que nous avons fait évoluer et
qui a évolué je le rappelle après le 1er
décembre
et puis il ya un phénomène constaté de
dépassement face à la violence en
question notamment l' usage moins
systématique des ailes bd les policiers
avaient eu l'autorisation de tirer
samedi pour arrêter instantanément les
délinquants en action ou devait-il
attentes des ordres qui ne venaient pas
il y a eu des instructions d'utilisation
plus prudente
plus mesuré des lanceurs de balles de
défense qui ont été données et ça
n'était pas ça ne correspondait pas aux
instructions générales qui avait été
donné par les ministres
en plus de la loi anti-casseurs adopté
au sénat le gouvernement a annoncé des
mesures pour mieux encadrer les
manifestations mais pas question pour le
ministre de l'intérieur d'aller vers
l'instauration d'un état d'urgence
je n'exclus pas l'état d'urgence par
principe je les skull parce que j'ai le
sentiment qu'il ne donnerait pas
forcément de moyens supplémentaires pour
neutraliser ceux qui viennent casser
au terme de trois heures d'audition les
explications de christophe castaner
n'ont pas convaincu tous les sénateurs
ce qui m'inquiète
c'est peut-être les risques que nous
allons comprendre que le pays va prendre
est ce que nos forces de police sont
préparés ils sont fatigués n'y aurait-il
pas des provocations samedi prochain il
y aura t'il pas des réponses
inutile en tout cas excessive à ces
provocations d'autres à l'image du
président de la commission des lois
salue cet exercice de clarification
c'était nécessaire après les événements
de samedi qui est ce temps d'écouté de
question de dialogue aussi pour que les
ministres comprennent que vous font ces
parlementaires qui viennent de tous les
départements de france ils sont porteurs
de quelque chose d'important
les sénateurs ont annoncé qu'ils
procéderont à des auditions
complémentaires
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet
sera entendu dans les prochains jours
alors jean pierre door avez vous été
convaincu par les explications de
christophe castaner là je crois pas je
crois pas je crois que ce qui s'est
encore passé la semaine le la dernière
le 18e date du xviiie manifestations à
paris et quand même quelque chose
d'effrayant
on sait nous voir cela sur toutes les
chaînes du monde entier
ça fait peur ça fait réellement peur et
de voir cet immeuble brûlés avec des
gens à l'intérieur de voir des commerces
saccagés à ce point là des vols c'est
véritablement moi j'ai envie de dire
c'est du terrorisme de rue
donc ce ne sont pas les manifestants eux
mêmes c'est toute cette bande qui vient
se greffer sur ces manifestations il
faut arrêter tout cela donc c'est pas
avec des policiers qui sont fatigués qui
se répète
semaine après semaine et qui sont dans
la limite à contrôler et à surveiller
mais pas agir c'est fini il faut se
rappeler que l'état d'urgence nous
l'avions fait en 2005 lors des violences
urbaines
cela a été refait l'ordre du terrorisme
en 2000
15 donc ça donne des idées des solutions
il fallait s'engager vers l'état
d'urgence le ministre de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui mais oui le ministre de
l'intérieur qui dit je ne suis pas
contre mais je pense que c'est pas
nécessaire il faut il devrait dire
plutôt c'est nécessaire je suis pour
il faut rentrer dans l'état d'urgence et
puis faire en sorte qu'on arrête toutes
ces bandes de voyous de délinquants de
terroristes qui viennent perturber les
manifestations et qui viennent agresser
on est la risée du monde en ce moment
il faut quand même arrêter 18
manifestations il y en aura-t-il
d'autres
alors c'est peut-être possible mais
malheureusement on ne va pas encore
résoudre le problème par michel delpech
un préfet de police de paris a été
limogé est ce que pour vous il a servi
de fusible est ce que christophe
castaner aurait dû démissionner bien
entendu ce sont des fusibles qui ont
sauté mais c'est pas moi j'ai souvenir
ils sont responsables il ya une
responsabilité politique et une
responsabilité du gouvernement est une
responsabilité du président de la
république on est quand même dans un
état de gravité urbaine en ce moment
dans paris mais aussi dans les autres
villes de province doit-on continuer
encore à voir se dérouler toutes ces
agressions toutes ces destructions de
camps mais le même l'économie française
et à et ans en dessous de ce qu'elle
devrait être
elle est au dessous du niveau normal
l'économie souffre les commerçants
souffrent ils savent plus à quel saint
se vouer
et puis comment vont-ils être
indemnisées comment cela va-t-il se
passer
on va arriver dans la période
touristique on a eu déjà les pertes de
noël qui ont été catastrophiques non il
faut stopper ils ont une responsabilité
c'est la responsabilité politique tout
simplement alors le premier ministre a
fait une série d'annoncés lundi parmi
celles ci le recours aux militaires de
l'opération sentinelles pour sécuriser
des bâtiments publics et des lieux fixes
le but est de libérer les les forces de
l'ordre pour qu'elles puissent faire
uniquement du maintien de l'ordre
que pensez vous de cette annonce je
pense alors celle là elle et elle est
satisfaisante mais c'est une forte
c'est une sorte de d'état d'urgence dont
il ne veut pas parler il faut même aller
plus loin il n'y a pas que les bâtiments
il y a également les forces
militaires doivent être contactés pour
venir en soutien de la police de la
gendarmerie terre disait ce n'est pas
leur travail de faire du maintien de
l'ordre
je sais bien mais ils peuvent être en
maintien derrière le rideau de la police
et de la gendarmerie
quand ça déborde trop ils peuvent
intervenir il faut quand même arrêter
ces voyous intervenir ça veut dire tirer
à non vous avez aussi la possibilité
d'arrêter quand vous avez vu sais je
sais je sais même pas s'ils sont des
jeunes qui voulaient et d'extirper un
policier d'une camionnette de police
la violence avec laquelle ce fait un
autre policier qui a failli être lynché
mais on va aller à des morts bientôt si
ça continue il faut assumer d'avoir des
blessés pendant les manifestations est
ce que plus de fermeté ça veut dire
assumer d'avoir des blessés viennent il
faudra peut-être que tous les
manifestants finissent par comprendre
aussi que leur manifestation il faut
qu'il la fasse de façon calme en dehors
de toute la bande de délinquants
sinon comme le disent certains on peut
on va croire que les manifestants
deviennent complices de ce qui se passe
dans la rue il faut donc aussi que eux
prennent leurs responsabilités puisque
manifester c'est normal c'est logique on
peut manifester en dehors de toutes ces
bandes de violence et le effectivement
l'état d'urgence pmm permettrait
peut-être de séparer les vrais
manifestants défaut manifestants et des
violences urbaines
allez on va passer à la loi santé
examiné cette semaine à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
près de deux mille amendements pour une
loi d'une vingtaine d'articles les
débats sur cette loi portée par agnès
buzyn ont été attrait nourrit cette
semaine dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale le texte vise à améliorer
l'offre de soins en particulier en
milieu rural et à lutter contre les
fameux déserts médicaux mais si le
numerus clausus a été supprimé d'autres
mesures visant à pousser les médecins
vers les zones sous-dotées ont
finalement été abandonnées résumé des
débats signée nathalie gloire lutter
contre les déserts médicaux
c'est l'un des objectifs de ce texte
première solution trouvée est adopté par
les députés
la fin du numerus clausus ce concours
limité chaque année le nombre
d'étudiants admis en deuxième année
d'étude de santé problème ces étudiants
ne seront sur le terrain que dans dix
ans
ça veut dire que les années qui viennent
vont être des années dramatique je
termine mal à leur exemple puisqu'il n'y
a pas de mesures d'urgence qui
permettent de remédier à la
désertification médicale
autre mesure de cette réforme le stage
obligatoire dans les déserts médicaux
pour les étudiants d'abord adopté en
commission à les rejeter dans
l'hémicycle et n'aura finalement pas
lieu
nous sommes dans l'incapacité d'envoyer
9000 étudiants en zones sous denses pour
une formation c'est techniquement pas
faisable
faut-il alors mettre fin à la liberté
d'installation des médecins pour les
députés de l'opposition c'est une
nécessité
certains proposent le conventionnement
sélectif comment on fait pour lutter
contre ces inégalités le
conventionnement cellectis est
extrêmement simple élément comme idée
c'est de dire aux médecins n'avaient
plus vous installer là où les besoins de
santé sont déjà pourvus et par pitié
cole laisse plus les médecins
s'installer là où on sait qu'elle n'a
déjà en trop je trouve que c'est d'une
immoralité terrible il faut cesser de
les conventionnés là où il ya déjà trop
de médecins sur cette question la
ministre reste inflexible
la coercition n'est pas une solution est
ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il vaut
mieux miser sur leur engagement et sur
leurs envies
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils donneront
le même temps
le même temps de consultation qui
verront le même nombre de malades
si on leur impose de s'installer sur un
territoire ou si au contraire ils ont
envie de construire leur vie si la
ministre refuse toute mesure de
coercition à la toutefois annoncé en
commission qu'elle lancerait une mission
pour évaluer les mesures incitatives
concédé aux praticiens qui s'installent
dans les déserts médicaux
alors jean pierre door sur la principale
mesure du texte d'abord la fin du
numerus clausus que dites-vous c'est une
bonne mesure mais qui ne suffira pas
bien entendu de la fin du numerus
clausus s'est logiquement fait c'est pas
la fin du numerus clausus c'est une
augmentation du numerus clausus de 20%
c'est à dire que l'on va passer de 8000
à 10000 étudiants parents qui se ruent
qui incorporeront la faculté nous
l'avions nous augmenter de trois mille
cinq à huit mille c'était déjà beaucoup
mais maintenant lui 1000 à 10000 tout à
fait logique
donc c'est simplement un report si vous
voulez une augmentation du nombre
d'étudiants mais cela sera effectif que
dans entre 10 et 15 ans c'est à dire
vers les années 2030 2035
donc c'est la méthode d'urgence elle est
pas là on l'a fait pendant les le grand
débat notamment il ya une question qui
inquiète les français c'est celle des
déserts médicaux est ce que pour vous ce
texte permet de répondre à cette
inquiétude du tout pas du tout les
déserts médicaux il existe parce que il
y a très peu d'étudiants qui s'installe
en médecine générale la filière de
médecine générale est une filière
pauvres aujourd'hui il ya moins de 10 %
d'étudiants qui en fin d'études
s'installe dans la médecine libérale
dont fait le calcul 10 - 10 % sur 8000
ça fait pas beaucoup sur les 100
départements
donc il ya un manque d'étudiants qui
vont vers la médecine alors quand on dit
on va les obliger d'aller là mais pour
les obliger faudra en avoir beaucoup
déjà il faudrait en avoir de façon
satisfaisante or vous ne pourrez pas les
obliger parce que ce sera contre
productif c'est ce qui a été dit par la
ministre est d'accord avec la mini sur
ce point que les régions coercitives
seraient contreproductives et comme on
fait parce que les mesures incitatives
n'a pas marché c'est dire si si si si si
si
le problème c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait
beaucoup plus j'ai envie de dire de
stock
d'étudiants en médecine qui s'installe
en médecine générale
donc il faut valoriser la filière de
médecine générale dans les facultés dans
les universités en particulier des
universités de province
donc il faut qu on est beaucoup plus
d'étudiants qui s'engagent dans la
médecine générale et on les verra
ensuite sur le terrain
alors oui la méthode contre
contraignante et contreproductif
elle a été expérimentée dans d'autres
pays européens qui ont le même problème
ça a été un échec
deuxièmement moi j'ai mis en garde c'est
que les jeunes médecins s'installeront
là où ils veulent aller parce qu'ils ont
un projet professionnel ils ont un
projet familial ils ont plus de 30 ans
quand il s'installe s'ils ont pas 25 ans
il entre en 32 33 ans et que ce qui va
se passer c'est qu'ils iront s'installer
où ils veulent mais ceux des
conventionnements dons qui seront ce
qu'on appelle le secteur 3 et ils auront
une patientèle
parce que c'est toute la france qui est
impactée par les airs médicaux quand
vous voyez que paris a perdu 25% du
nombre de généralistes donc le le
principe c'est qu'il y a un défaut dans
la filière des médecins généralistes
depuis des années ils se sont dirigés
vers les spécialités
il y a une plus grande féminisation donc
là aussi il ya les problèmes de couple
le problème de de maternité et c'est
donc qu'il ya un changement réel de la
situation
l'observatoire de la démographie
médicale le confirme pour voir que très
très peu de médecins s'installent alors
remis les histoires le salarié parmi les
mesures d'urgence assemblée a voté jeudi
le fait que les pharmaciens puissent
délivrer dans certains cas sans
ordonnance des médicaments par exemple
pour des angines en cas d'urgence les
médecins se disent inquiets vous les
comprenez je les comprends je pense que
le pharmacien est un acteur de santé un
professionnel de santé il fait partie
d'ailleurs des de la coordination des
soins
dans le cas des communautés
professionnelles santé territoires mais
la prescription doit être initialement
décidée par un médecin parce que même
une angine
si vous voulez ne nécessite pas toujours
un antibiotique
donc il faut savoir aller on a parlé des
cystites moi je ne sais pas ce que ce
qu'est une cystite réellement ça peut
aller de la simple petite brûlure à
quelque chose de plus grave et qui
nécessitent un examen
donc tout cela doit être réfléchie donc
je crois que ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il y
ait des rapprochements des consensus
entre médecins et pharmaciens pour
savoir comment pourront se passer les
prescriptions pharmaceutique
moi je sais que les pharmaciens en
général peuvent aussi par téléphone
avoir un écran un communication avec le
médecin qui donne son indication à
prescrire ou pas allez on en vient jean
pierre door à notre dernier thème les
hésitations du gouvernement sur les
retraites
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi le sénat se pencher sur la réforme
des retraites au cours d'un colloque en
présence de gérard larcher et jean paul
delevoye le haut commissaire à la
réforme colloque prévu de longue date
mais qui tombe et au milieu d'une
semaine de cacophonie gouvernementale
sur la question de l'âge de départ à la
retraite agnès buzyn a ouvert la porte à
un report avant de la refermer mercredi
benjamin griveaux affirme que la
question est bien nos menus de la
concertation mercredi encore sommé par
l'opposition de démêler cet imbroglio le
premier ministre a tenté de clarifier la
position de l'exécutif écoutez c'était
lors des questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée
il n'est pas question le haut
commissaire a dit dans le cadre de cette
réforme
il n'est pas question de modifier l'âge
de départ à la retraite c'est la
première partie de là c'est la première
partie de votre question à laquelle je
veux apporter une réponse mais il y à
madame la députée dans votre question
une deuxième question qui est celle de
la prise en charge du vieillissement de
notre population et dans ce contexte de
vieillissement et d'un besoin de
financement considérable se poser la
question de savoir s'il faut travailler
plus longtemps
question parfaitement valide madame la
députée ce qui m'inquièterait serait qu
on ne se la pose pas alors jean pierre
door vous avez vous même posé une
question au gouvernement juste après la
réponse du premier ce qu'on vient
d'entendre avez vous compris sa position
non non non je lui ai posé la question
parce qu'il ya eu une cacophonie au sein
du gouvernement la semaine dernière
entre la ministre de la santé des
solidarités qui devant une chaîne de
télévision dit qu'effectivement
peut-être qu'il faudra allonger l'âge de
la retraite
et puis le haut commissaire chargé de de
l'étude de la retraite qui est sous
tutelle de la ministre de la santé
déclare le lendemain il en est pas
question on ne bougera pas l'âge de la
retraite le premier ministre comme le
prétend la république ont annoncé dans
leur programme qu'on ne toucherait pas à
l'âge de la retraite donc on ne sait
plus sur quel pied danser
c'est le moment de le dire donc il ya
des grandes difficultés frémiot d'un peu
de réfléchir de nous proposer leurs
propositions la proposition de l'état
r les retraites entre l'âge entre la
pénibilité il faut y toucher à l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite il faut le
recul et ce sera probablement une de nos
propositions à nous parce qu'il est
certain que compte tenu de l'espérance
de vie qui s'allonge d'un an tous les
quatre ans où on vit beaucoup plus
longtemps
et bien qu'on puisse travailler un peu
plus s'il on aura un peu plus adéquat le
sénat 10 63 ans votre collègue eric
woerth dit 65 ans ça peut aller jusqu'à
65 ans a fait peut se faire de façon
progressive sur de nombreuses années
63 64 65 ans en fonction de l'espérance
de vie et d'espérance et puis ensuite
ensuite suivant la pénibilité de
certains métiers merci beaucoup merci
jean pierre door d'avoir été reçus cette
semaine
merci steam on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]